if you as a person want to be able to do
something other than sitting on the
sidelines while history makes the
decisions for you then you have to take
a side you have to pick the one that you
think is the best and throw yourself
into repairing and making that as best
as it can be the alternative they're
facing is to just let the woke
neo-marxas swim not just to win at the
level of government but also to win in
your personal life and what I'm saying
is that there there has to be an
alternative and think about it for a
second that alternative is not going to
be liberalism it's not going to be
liberalism because liberalism is what
brought woke Neo Mark to them it's every
single institution that the wolf Neil
marxists are running now was a liberal
institution 15 years ago so if
liberalism had the antibodies if it was
enough to say let's just be free if that
was strong enough to be able to defeat
open near Marxism we wouldn't be where
we are today
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
And Timely guest today is the author of
a new book conservatism a rediscovery
Europe has only welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me it's a pleasure
uh we cannot wait uh to speak with you
we've got some very interesting things
to discuss before we do though other
than being the author of this book tell
everybody who are you how are you where
you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us
okay the very the very short version if
you want the long version read the book
the short version is
um I I live in Jerusalem married to Yael
we have nine children and at this point
three three grandchildren thank God more
on the way
um I uh grew up in the United States as
you can hear I've met my wife in in
college we've founded a uh a a Reagan
Thatcher publication in college called
the Princeton Tory and uh since then
I've been uh in involved in uh in Jew
Jewish and Israeli ideas I have a
doctorate in political Theory I I've
published some books on uh on on the
Bible and its relevance to to us today
and uh most recently after the 2016
after 2016 the the the the brexit Trump
year
um I gathered with some friends and
colleagues and we founded an
international organization called the
the Edmund Burke Foundation which
operates uh in in in various Democratic
uh countries the Edmund Burke Foundation
is uh runs the national conservatism
conferences uh which uh which have been
taking place for several years annually
in the United States and in Europe and
there's going to be a not con UK uh this
this coming spring
well jorm it's uh great to have you on
the show because one of the things you
talk about in the book and uh you're not
the only one talking about it because I
think quite a lot of smart people are
starting to realize uh what I'm about to
say I heard Peter Thiel talking at an At
Con event uh in the US uh and everybody
you know me my friends Francis we're all
starting to understand that you know we
all know what we're against we're
against the idiocy of wokeness a lot of
us uh Francis and I particular also
against some of the idiocy of the
anti-wokness that's starting to filter
through there are things that we all
oppose but the question I think for a
lot of people is well what are we for
exactly what do we believe because you
know the caricature version of sort of
owning the libs uh gets old very quickly
it's uninspiring it doesn't offer
anything it's not something that a young
person in particular can look at and go
this is what this is what I want to be
the view of life that I have this is how
I'm going to go through life these are
the things I'm going to build it's
negative it's deconstructive rather than
being constructive there's no optimism
there's no creativity there's no
building of anything so what is it that
conservatism of the way of the vision
that you describe has to offer to those
people who are perhaps looking for some
kind of Middle Ground between those two
extremes
well let let's be let's begin with with
liberalism because I I think the most
important thing to understand is that
the 2020 was a was a watershed year uh
in in Britain in America and uh across
many other democratic nations it was the
year that liberal ideas which had been
dominant you can say hegemonic at least
since the second world war 2020 was the
year that that uh hegemony dominance of
liberalism broke and the way that you
can you can tell that is that the the
traditional liberal perspective let me
let me just Define it for a second the
traditional liberal perspective which
says in in order to understand to know
what you need to know about politics and
about life what what liberals will say
what you need to know is that
individuals are by Nature free and equal
that we take on moral and political
obligations on the basis of consent and
that the purpose of government is is to
defend our rights
that had been for 50 60 70 years uh the
the basis for public life and most of
the political most of the major
political parties in in the west
embraced one version or another of that
liberalism now conservatism is a is a
different is a different Beast
conservatism is conservatives begin from
the question of
I'm I'm born into a family a a nation a
religious tradition I'm I'm born into
various things that I did not create I
didn't construct them I might want to
improve them to add to them to build
them up I might want to reform them I
might want to restore them but the
conservative asks about the inheritance
that we've received and fundamentally
wants to know what do we need to do in
order to uh so that uh so that our
nation our our religion our political
inheritance can propagate across
Generations so as as you'll see in my
book if you if you if you take a look at
it the difference between this
difference between someone who wants to
um to uh create a space in which we can
all uh pursue our own thing that's
that's the liberal and conservative is
that the conservative says look we've
inherited many things and many of those
things are good and we need to figure
out how to build them up it conservatism
is fundamentally a creative project and
those two groups anti-marxist liberals
anti-marxist conservatives we do have to
fight to fight side by side against the
common uh woke uh opposite uh the the
the woke cultural revolution
which is on the verge of uh of of
winning but liberalism and conservatism
are two different things and and we will
will each in the end have to decide
which side of that argument we're on as
well well we gotta we gotta win the
fight in terms of wokeness first but I
suppose the reason I bring up a positive
vision of the future which I think is
sorely lacking or with everyone who
opposes wokeness at the moment uh is
that the question for me is why would I
join your fight from an Outsiders but I
know why I'm against working this
because it mimics many of the terrible
things that I saw happen in my own and
my family's history and Francis likewise
but if I'm just a normal person in in
the UK or in America and I'm not too
bothered about you know all the stuff
that I see on social media maybe I'm not
on social media why should I be either
one of these liberals or one of these
conservatives and oppose it so harshly
if you don't have a slogan for me you
know join our fight and you get this
this and this or you get to keep this
and this and this but that's how people
think right why should I be on your side
your own well
conservatives believe and I think this
is true and I think that more and more
people will see this conservatives
believe that in order to be a healthy
happy human being uh you you actually
have to be part of uh of an inheritance
uh which is then being handed down again
I I want to emphasize that that doesn't
mean you have to believe everything that
is inherited but
conservatives think that you human
nature is such that if you raise
children uh and you tell them look do
whatever you want do whatever feels good
use your own reason exercise your own
thinking and come to your own
conclusions and you don't give them
anything else
a great great many people maybe the
majority uh end up stuck and unable to
make the decisions among you know what
what exactly is it that I'm I'm I'm
supposed to do and what is it I'm
supposed to believe so we we have to
start somewhere and I I suggest that the
question you know as I posed it that we
begin with what is it that you've
inherited that you yourself actually uh
would like to see handed down to your
children to your grandchildren uh or or
let's say into the future maybe you
don't have children yet so that that
that's that's a question so
traditional traditional World Views a
Christian worldview a Jewish world view
a a nationalist worldview a conservative
world view all of these World Views what
they do is they uh they they place you
within a uh with a within a kind of a
hierarchy where the past hands down
things uh your your ancestors hand down
things your parents your your community
hands down things
and you have a responsibility to uh to
to fight for those things you say why
should you fight well if if if you think
that there are some things that are
better than other things then then you
should fight I mean it it doesn't feel
good to not fight if you're you're
watching terrible things happening and I
think that's where we are I think we are
watching terrible things happening
like what do you mean by terrible things
joram
well look I I'm going I'm going to
describe this from uh from my own
perspective and I know that you know
many of your listeners you can get on or
get off you know what as as you see fit
the the uh the the world that uh Brits
and Americans and others fought for in
the Second World War uh was was a world
in which uh there there was a a
framework of ideas those ideas
um let's name some of them uh God and
scripture nation and family
um uh man and woman honor the sacred uh
the the the uh the Beautiful the free
all of these ideas are ideas that if if
you take a look at
what have what has wokism been been
doing since since it's uh since its
initial victory in 2020 what it's doing
is overthrowing all of these inherited
Concepts
okay so so uh as a a Christian friend
just told me a few weeks ago he said
look and here in Colorado he he helps
run a university there he said here in
Colorado
um we used to have this wonderful
liberal idea that uh that each should be
free to uh to choose his own religion or
lack of religion in his own path and now
we've moved from that being the default
position in society to the default being
that if uh if you don't honor in this
particular case the the the issue was
gay marriage but you don't have to agree
about that it can be other things if you
don't honor gay marriage we will force
you publicly uh to to to honor it
there's no such thing anymore as as a as
a personal View and a PRI a private view
now if you're the kind of person who
thinks
um that uh that the old liberalism uh
where uh where we we inculcated and
attempted to hand on uh religious
Liberties if you think that that's not
worth worth fighting for so uh you know
what what can I what can I tell you if
you don't if you don't think that
marriage is something that is worth
fighting for or that having children in
the future or that Britain continuing to
exist is something worth fighting for so
I I understand you I feel for you but
most people are not like you most people
they get meaning out of Life by
selecting those things that appear to be
be overall good and just and uh and and
uh working to build them up that's you
know that's how we know that we're doing
something that's that's worthy in life
you're I'm gonna ask you two questions
number one if as a conservative do you
have to be religious do you have to
believe in a religion
and number two there's another question
hasn't religion played its own his part
in its own time for particularly
organized religion when you look at the
corruption endemic in the church for
instance I was raised Catholic I look at
what the Catholic has done particularly
its abuses when it comes to Children the
the rancid cover-ups of success of
numerous popes I'm like no wonder people
don't believe it anymore after what they
have done
okay well look first of all I'm not I
I'm I'm not a Catholic I'm I'm an
orthodox Jew and I I don't want to be
pulled into
um you know into trying to to uh to
defend a particular uh religious
framework I mean I I certainly there are
you know my my good friend Rod drier was
uh was uh was a Catholic and he was one
of the uh reporters who led the uh the
the the the
um uh in in the 2000s the investigations
the journalistic investigations into uh
into the things you're describing in the
church and he himself decided uh to
convert to Orthodox Christianity uh
because of his because of his
experiences with the Catholic church now
look my a religious worldview is one
that begins by saying
um human beings are crummy Christians
say human beings are Fallen we we just
don't speak that way but we we do think
that human beings are are
um are extremely fallible and and uh
tend towards all sorts of evil things
and
um every Human Institution and every
human political Theory uh whether you
know whether it's liberal or
conservative Christian or Jewish or or
or
any other imperialist or nationalist
every human ideology is going to have
examples of people who are bad people
and policies that are bad policies and
evil things that are done in its name
okay you know people people say to me
isn't the church evil and uh you know
certainly the church has done evils but
you you know the to the evils of the
church actually uh compete with the
evils of atheists like Stalin and Hitler
and Mao well okay you we can argue about
this but I think you know where we
started was uh was what brings what
brings meaning to the life of the
individual uh an individual sitting on
the sideline saying why should I fight
um I I'm not saying that you should
fight for every single inherited
tradition I'm saying that you yourself
will get take up meaning and self-esteem
and re and and self-worth when you join
a community that you think is on the
whole uh something that improves human
life that on the whole hands down things
that make things uh better so look I I
always tell people if you grew up in a
Christian family then you should start
with Christianity because that's your
inheritance but somebody who finds the
road blocked and uh uh should they
should they pursue uh Judaism or some
other inheritance it's possible my my my
my wife uh grew up in a Christian family
and she she uh in adults would became a
convert to Judaism and I know people who
went the opposite direction as well and
so look there's every single tradition
that you point to you can find uh things
things that are uh wrong and even even
evil with it every single one but if you
as a person want to be able to do
something other than sitting on the
sidelines while history makes the
decisions for you then you have to take
aside you have to pick the one that you
think is the best and throw yourself
into repairing and making that as best
as it can be
and what do you think is going to happen
you're if we don't pick a side
uh well the the the
um uh look I I I think the writing is
already on the wall I mean uh
look we can we can make light of uh of
woke as an online phenomenon uh but I
don't I don't think it's simply an
online phenomenon I woke is woke is a
descendant of uh of Marxism and it um uh
it it it chapter seven of my book I I I
I I go into exactly why but it's it's a
it is a framework that uh sees sees
human societies as consisting of
contending groups uh and defines whoever
is strongest which by the way I I think
that's reasonable that part but uh but
marxists go further and they say that
whoever is the the leading group the
dominant group is uh inevitably
oppressing and exploiting the weaker
groups and instead of seeking some kind
of accommodation and uh that will allow
the different groups to to get what they
need and to live in peace uh Marx calls
for the the exploited groups to
overthrow and Destroy uh the the ruling
class the dominant class now this wokism
is a is is a is a version of this Theory
it it is both explicitly and implicitly
a revolutionary movement whose purpose
is to destroy whatever it is that the
the dominant classes have inherited the
dominant in classes in in Britain and
most other Western countries today are
liberal and what wokeism seeks to
destroy be above and beyond anything
else is the dominant liberalism now what
do you what do you get if uh if if uh
you you destroy the dominant liberalism
and you don't have some some kind of uh
sophisticated and uh healthful
conservatism to to replace it what what
you get is an ongoing Revolution which
will will look like a communist country
if you want if you if you want if you
want to live in the old Soviet Union
that's the direction that we're going
um what evidence do you have for this
your what have you seen that that is
saying to you that we're moving towards
you the USSR or like in my case
Venezuela
what's the evidence look if if if you um
if you read history
especially right now we're talking about
the history of ideas right we're talking
we're talking about what is the dominant
idea in a place like like the Soviet
Union and and how does that end up
working out and the the the claim that
the marxists always made
um the their their claim was Injustice
is the result of the evil that is done
in the name of uh uh of the bourgeoisie
that's what we call liberalism today the
liberal classes they they claim to bring
freedom and equality but in fact what
they bring is oppression okay that that
was Marx's argument and it's now been
tried as as a political system in you
know in dozens of countries
um and uh including including in
Venezuela and in in uh in in Russia and
China there hasn't been a single
instance in which the revolution that
Marx calls for that some version of it
has been brought into being that that
doesn't uproot and Destroy both the
things that are inherited and cherished
that are conservative like
religion and family uh and nation and
the things that are inherited that are
liberal the the the Liberties and the
freedoms both what's good about
conservatism and what's good about
liberalism is is annihilated by Marxism
so what we're looking at the people who
are who who actually Advocate this uh uh
this world view they say well look it's
not it's not the old Marxism because
we've we've uh replaced the uh the
revolution of economic classes with a
revolution of uh of uh uh uh gen
identity groups a revolution of of
gender groups and racial groups and and
and others sexual orientation and so on
and that claim has actually I mean it it
it's interesting it's true that's the
reason we call this neo-marxism instead
of Marxism is is because of the fact
that there is a shift when the
revolution is not strictly an economic
Revolution but I guess guess what guess
what the wok neon Marxism by moving away
from the economic revolution of the old
Marxism they've given this great gift to
the woke which is that the woke can take
over a capitalist uh companies can take
over
um uh highly profitable companies highly
profitable and uh and prestigious
universities in other words the woke can
simply become the new ruling structure
in place of liberalism but the idea of
oppressing and destroying anyone who
disagrees remains from the old Marxism
so it's an improved Marxism in in the
sense that it looks like it's more
effective but in the sense that you know
that anyone who's who's lived under such
a regime would want to repeat the
experiment I I doubt that very much
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we show an intimate moment as we watch a
Japanese tourists get trapped in a tube
door that is good but I wasn't talking
about their locals I was talking about
our community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes content when you thank
you space
when you get to ask incredible guests
like Jordan Peterson we're at Weinstein
Bill Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Heather Hein and others your questions
not just that you can get supporter only
benefits like trigonometry mugs monthly
calls with our other top supporters and
even a regular meal with me and Francis
you also get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes footage of our trip to
America where we met a whole host of
incredible guests and gave ourselves
terminal indigestion we're also starting
to do monthly giveaways for locals only
the first one will be signed copies of
Andrew Dawes new book plus you get
access to an incredible community of
like-minded people who share means have
fun conversations and most importantly
you get to make new friends you can
support us with as little as seven
dollars or about five pounds a month or
give us more for the higher tier
benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
well this is why Francis and I both
opposed workers before we understood any
of these terms because we were just two
idiot Comedians and suddenly we started
talking to people like you who could
explain things but instinctively it's
very clear that this is a highly
illiberal ideology that wants to shut
things down prevent people from
expressing their views prevent people
from opposing publicly what they say
because if you oppose it you must be you
can't just be counted with argument you
have to be destroyed you're a bad person
TM right so totally with you on that
you're on but one thing coming back to
our earlier conversation about what what
you have to offer the world I would say
to you that your slogan has got to be
meaning and fulfillment because as
someone who became a father for the
first time seven months ago now I am
starting to realize very quickly that as
something Francis actually always said
which is you know the Fulfillment that
you experience in your life depends
primarily on the people around you your
family your friends you know are they
well are they unwell you connected with
them are you disconnected from them and
these are all the things that any form
of Marxism will instinctively attempt to
destroy but it's because like religion
these are things that tie you in uh and
that that I think is something that is
definitely people that you should run
with which is you're offering people
meaning and happiness and fulfillment in
the world in which people take a crap
ton of antidepressants and all the rest
of it but I want to come back to
something that you mentioned which has
become a very dirty word uh in in our
politics in the UK in America and
elsewhere which is nationalism the idea
of the nation itself is a Highly
Questionable construct I would put it to
you and anyone who seeks to bring Shrine
or protect it is automatically racist
xenophobic hates people with different
skin colors Etc uh is is that first of
all do you think that's accurate that
that is how we know how we see that term
but also how do you can you detoxify it
do you need a new word do you need a new
vision you know talk to us about
nationalism and why it's become such a
dirty word look I in general I like the
old words because because you are
conservative it makes sense no I but but
but for a reason I think I I think that
when previous generations uh worked and
developed uh developed a word it's
usually part of a a scheme it's usually
part of a group of ideas rather than an
individual word and in in general
um these inherited schemes of ideas
they're what allow us to find uh not
only meaning but but even truth in
reality that doesn't mean that the
inherited schemes don't sometimes need
to be repaired but I I when when I hear
an old word
um I before I reject it I would like to
know what was good about that word what
was true about it you know maybe in the
end I'll decide that I don't like it but
I want to know why did it work so well
and the uh the idea of the nation and
the independent nation with the the the
term nationalism is I I think that
you're right that there you know are
many uh liberal but especially Marxist
circles in which the word nationalism is
uh is a you know some kind of terrible
word and the the reason for it is pretty
straightforward
um that uh the the idea of nationalism
is uh the idea that the world is
governed best when there are many
different independent nations that can
each one can chart its own course
according to its own traditions and its
own ideas now this this idea enters
enters into uh the history of the world
uh in in the time of the Bible it's a
very very old idea
um the the
um the Bible when I'm talking about the
Bible as a as a political document I'm
not you don't have to you know believe
in one religion or another to understand
what I'm saying the the the Bible is
politically it's an anti-imperial
anti-imperial document it's filled with
um with Empires whose goal is to conquer
the entire world so that's the Assyrian
Empire the Babylonian Empire the
Egyptians the Persians the the uh the
the the Romans later all of these
Empires are they're very different from
one another but they have one thing or
at least one thing in common which is
that each one of them has a God or gods
that orders the king to conquer the four
corners of the Earth in order to bring
peace and prosperity to Mankind and
that's not that's not a stupid dream the
idea of Conquering the whole world
because the the claim is that when the
world is divided then there are
ceaseless Wars and conquests and these
these these wars destroy the economy
they they bring disease and death and so
the goal of the imperialist is to is
always to eliminate uh competition and
Warfare and to bring peace and
prosperity the Bible
Rebels against this worldview and says
look no that's that's not the right way
the right way is that each Nation should
have a border that it doesn't cross each
Nation should be independent it should
find its own way to God it should have a
a king as it says in Deuteronomy a king
that comes from its own people uh
prophets that come from its own people
in other words it's an it's an argument
for uh for the freedom of
um large groups of people if the freedom
of society is to say we don't want to go
the way a different Society is going we
want to go our way and to try to make
that work and uh so a nationalist is
somebody who'll say
look
um let's try to have this tolerance for
other nations that do things differently
from us and in the end it may turn out
that their way is in some ways better
than ours and then we'll be able to
learn from them and vice versa okay so
when when the the the the word
nationalist is is used and it's sort of
uh normative sense in the last couple of
centuries it was it was usually a
progressive term it was a a a a term
that said instead of somebody sitting in
you know in in Beijing or in in
Washington and deciding how the the
entire planet should be operated why
don't we allow uh different different
ways of life different uh ways of
thinking to flourish and we'll find out
in the long term which one which one is
best
[Music]
I'm sure that is the trajectory of How
It's been used before but that's not
what the word nationalism means if you
read it in a newspaper today a
nationalist is someone who hates
immigrants who doesn't want who wants to
close the borders uh who is uh quite
likely to be some kind of ideological
descendant either of Adolf Hitler who
was a German nationalist or uh people
might look around and go well Vladimir
Putin he's reincarnated a Russian
nationalism which is causing the war in
Ukraine that's what people think about
quite often now when they talk about
nationalism and so when you say National
conservatism it's like it's it's both
those bad words in one combination
Europe
okay well uh guilty for having combined
the words
um and uh and and uh if if the if the
words scare people well you know that's
not so bad that means we can have a good
a good a good discussion about it the
the
um uh look at your you you're you're
sort of right about Hitler and you're
sort of wrong about Putin or I don't
know if if you're asking on behalf of
someone else but someone who says that
Putin is a nationalist uh is simply
ignorant no I agree he's an imperialist
primarily he is but but he is building
up He is building a Russian nationalism
in terms of we Russians we're Superior
to others Etc that is happening if look
every every Empire is is run by you know
one one nation or one or two Nations but
just to be just to be clear about this
in Putin's own speech now I'm talking
about the way he understands himself
Putin Putin sees Russia explains Russia
as a multinational a multinational
Federation you know something like the
austro-hungarian Empire he doesn't he
that's his that's the way that he
present for him he the the the the
Nationalist Nazis are the ukrainians
because they stand up in the way of the
multinational Empire that he's trying to
build okay so so let's put fujin aside
Hitler is more interesting because uh
because Hitler does in fact use the word
word nationalism and so for for uh me to
uh uh to try to revive the earlier use
of the word which which is what I'm
doing I do really have to deal with the
fact that you know Hitler's mind conf
which I you know I don't I don't
recommend the book but if you if you
read it then you'll see that uh that the
way that Hitler uh appropriates the word
nationalism he takes it away from you
know from the from from the Nationalist
Visionaries uh of the 19th century who
were you know uh who spoke the way I
speak and and he says well actually I
have a new new definition of the word
nationalism and uh and and you'll see
that it's the opposite he uses the word
to mean to mean the opposite he
explicitly treats the idea of
independent nation and he rejects them
he rejects the idea of a world of
independent nations he explicitly says
that there needs to be a biological
competition among races and that that
competition has to end with Germany
being the Mistress of the globe and Lord
of the earth okay so so that by the
traditional definition Hitler is a
biological imperialist there is no
nationalism in Hitler despite the fact
that he used that word now we have to
decide since he's taken he's taken what
I think was it was basically a good
sound word and he's he's corrupted it
and turned it into its opposite so what
should I do so some people say okay
let's just drop the word nationalism
let's say let's call it patriotism okay
so that's that's for example Orwell or
we'll say okay let's give the word
nationalism to Hitler and we'll just
call ourselves Patriots the the pro the
problem uh that that I have with this
other than the fact that I don't like
the fact that that a tradition that I
inherited from my father and from my
ancestors that that tradition needs to
be given up because of uh because among
other things Hitler not only uh killed
my people and yours uh but uh but uh and
and and destroyed Europe but also in
addition we have to give up our
traditional terms because he he
destroyed those two so in part I just
don't I don't like that but I also have
you know as a as a scholar of the
subject I I have a little bit of a
problem which is that sometimes when you
give up words you cease to be able to
express the idea properly and patriotism
is uh it's it's very close to
nationalism but patriotism is refers uh
it in every usage that I'm familiar with
it refers to loving your own country
I'm I'm a patriot of uh of England or of
the UK I'm a patriot of of Israel or of
America or of India
um that's a perfectly good usage of the
word but patriotism is not a description
never has been used as a description for
a proposal for a the best for for a
better world order nationalism is a
description it's a proposal for how to
better run the world it doesn't just say
I love my country nationalism means I I
I I love my country but I also make
space for my neighbors to love their
country that's the reason that a border
between us is is a useful thing because
good good borders make good neighbors so
nationalism is uh I I in 2018 I
published a book called The Virtue of
nationalism nationalism is a is a virtue
to the extent that what it means is that
we develop the type of Personality that
is capable of on the one hand seeking
out what's what's good and worthy in our
own in our own Nation but on the other
recognizing the the uh the boundaries of
what we understand and allowing that
other people should have that same
freedom to to to experiment and try to
create something good that's different
in their Nation now I if you give up the
word nationalism the problem is there is
no substitute for that word you you
simply erase the political Theory I had
just described because there's no there
is no other word for it
isn't part of the problem as well with
nationalism in Europe is that this idea
that our way of life is better which
then leads to the Arrogant assumption
that you can then impose your way of
life and your belief system on other
countries as in bringing democracy to
Iraq Etc and it doesn't work because
people are fundamental these people are
fundamentally different their culture is
different yes I I I I agree with you but
I think that uh but I I think that what
you're describing is a liberal
imperialism it is it is it is uh look
let me let me just back up for one
second
um conservatism is is unlike
conservatism which is a world view
that's based on on different traditions
in different places and different times
conservatism isn't it's not a universal
theory like liberalism or Marxism
liberalism and Marxism are both of them
are theories that claim that they have
the answer for how we should be governed
in every time in every place in history
that's what makes them them both in
different ways revolutionary uh
revolutionary ideologies or political
theories a liberal who says that and and
this has been a great many uh uh
liberals have have made this argument
that that Locke or uh Rousseau or
Spinoza or Kant or their descendants
that they discovered the universal
answer to how all human beings must live
the only the one legitimate way to live
and Rousseau says explicitly the the
others say it implicitly Rousseau says
explicitly there is only one legitimate
Constitution which is which is The
Enlightenment liberal Constitution any
other Constitution Rousseau says that if
it varies in the slightest then it's
illegitimate and has to be overthrown
now when we're talking about these the
this this uh reprehensible theory that
uh that uh uh people sitting in
Washington or or you know in London or
in Brussels that their political
worldview is so correct that it
justifies going to Iraq or Afghanistan
or any other corner of the world and
imposing that worldview on a different
country that is precisely liberal
imperialism and it's it is inherent in
Enlightenment liberalism because of the
claim that that the liberal theory is
universal that it's the only correct
theory for all times and places you
reminded me uh someone who grew up in
the Soviet Union you mentioned that
Marxism has this uh you know feeling
that it can explain everything
everywhere there was a there was an old
Soviet joke about a guy who invents a
public shaving machine uh and he goes to
the whatever commissary that's supposed
to evaluate this potential new invention
and he explains the model he says well
what happens is you stick your face in
it and these blades come out and they
cut off your stubble and everything is
fine and the guy looks at him goes yeah
but everyone's got a different face
shape and you know body type and
everything you know different stubble
length uh you know people might put
their face in and it's not the right
shape and when he says well don't worry
it's only the first time repeat for
using repeatedly using it is going to
fix that problem isn't it but you
mentioned the
um that is that is the way these people
think that they've got the one solution
that's fit one size fits all it always
works and if if it doesn't work it's
because you are at fault as opposed to
the machine that they came up with that
that's a that's exactly that's
explicitly exactly what what we're told
is is you spent 20 years trying to to
bring liberal liberalism to Afghanistan
uh Why didn't it work well look there
there are also sorts of problems in the
execution
there's always problems in the execution
there's never ever a flaw in the idea
right uh but what I was really piqued my
curiosity uh in what you were saying is
you mentioned that conservatism doesn't
have that view right and can you explain
a little bit more about that difference
yes um if you'll allow me again to just
just touch on on on the Bible there's
this
um
remarkable
um uh issue in that I think you you see
it almost immediately when when you
start studying the Hebrew Bible is that
uh Moses is supposed to be talking to
God creator of Heaven and Earth and he
gets a law from you know the law from
God the Ten Commandments and so on and
and this law is supposed to be something
that's going to improve
um conditions For All Mankind and
there's all sorts of texts that say so
now the question is so if that's if this
is a universal
um thought you know these Ten
Commandments then then why does God give
Moses borders and say you're not allowed
to cross them you're not allowed to take
one inch of your neighbor's land uh
because I've given their land to to
these other nations
and so there there is this tension from
the very beginning in the uh uh in the
Jewish and Christian tradition which is
uh you know played out also in in uh in
England the common law tradition and in
the UK and that tension is between the
thought that we actually think that
we've discovered something that would be
that could be good for many other
peoples
but on the other hand that doesn't give
us the right to go out and conquer them
and impose these ideas by force
so this is this is kind of this is the
the original source of uh of the
anglo-american conservative tradition uh
which which wants to say on the one hand
there is something that is that is
uniquely good uh about Britain there is
something that's uniquely good about the
the uh the British or the American
tradition but the to take the additional
step which says the fact that we have
something uniquely good gives us a right
to impose it on others
that that that's where it's supposed to
stop so if you take let's say
um John Ford excusing Praise of the laws
of of England which you if you you
haven't read it I I recommend it to
especially to Brits but to everybody
it's a short book it's it's believe it
or not it's from the 1400s and you just
open it it's like it's it's beautifully
written like it was written you know
yesterday and uh and uh Fortescue says
look the common law the laws of England
they just are the best laws that
anybody's ever had but then he starts he
turns to France and Germany and he
addresses the question of you know
should the French and the Germans simply
adopt the English Constitution he says
no because the the laws of France and
Germany may be better suited for their
conditions for their their their
economic conditions their religious
conditions the the character of the
people he he leaves open the possibility
that over time things could be changed
and improved in France or Germany but he
doesn't he he disallows the the the the
step that goes because we have the
freest country and we have the best laws
therefore they should be adopted by
others
jorm do you think part of the problem
with your message is to put it bluntly
conservatism and nationalism on sexy
well but they're not like no one puts
Edmund Burke on a t-shirt I'm sorry I've
seen loads of Che Guevara I've never
seen Edmund Burke you know look isn't
that isn't that the real challenge here
yeah look I don't know me maybe if I can
maybe if I convince you know sexy guys
like yourselves
you're barking up the wrong tree my
friend then we'll have some kind of Hope
of winning you know because
you're right I'm just yeah like this
Poor's love right writes books I I
succeeded in conning my wife into
thinking that it was worth throwing in
with me
um but you know what can I tell you
um let's um let's make the following the
the following agreement
um I may not know how to make something
sexy uh but it doesn't it doesn't mean
necessarily that it's not going to
appeal to a young generation which is
facing here's the alternative they're
facing the alternative they're facing is
to just let the woke neo-marxists win
not just to win at the level of
government but also to win in your
personal life and what I'm saying is
that there there has to be an
alternative and think about it for a
second that alternative is not going to
be liberalism okay it's not going to be
liberalism because liberalism is what
brought woke neo-marxism it's the every
single institution that the woke Neo
marxists are running now was a liberal
institution 15 years ago so if
liberalism had the antibodies if it was
enough to say let's just be free if that
was strong enough to be able to defeat
woke Neo Marxism we wouldn't be where we
are today so sexy or not people have to
ask the following question I think they
have to if I want to have as you say
meaning fulfillment purpose a decent
life for me my family my friends my
children my grandchildren if I want that
so I have to I have no choice I have to
start thinking about what did I inherit
which gave me the possibility of a
decent life and what can I do to make
sure that it's handed down today that is
in a sense a a it's a
counter-revolutionary thought to say to
say liberalism wasn't good enough it
brought Marxism what can we do now let's
let let's look through the closet of the
things that we have in our inheritance
and see what could actually what used to
work what could work for us look I
I don't know when I was 18 I thought
that was pretty exciting
well there you go but you're um you you
make an interesting point and I I want
to ask you something about liberalism
because this is a question I've been
wrestling with uh first of all I'd love
for you to explain why you believe that
liberalism has been as susceptible as it
has been to this illiberal ideology and
also once once you've kind of in fact
why don't you answer that and I'll ask
you the question well look the the the
question here is is really about what
are human beings really like okay
because because
liberals assume and I again I'm talking
about the the the thing that's handed
down from from uh from from uh lock and
spinos and Hobbs and content and all the
way down to today where you know
liberalism and Marxism are the two
things that are basically taught in the
universities and and so the the basic
idea what is a human being like
that liberals start with and end with is
human beings are fundamentally free
creatures that are rational they can
make their own decisions they'll get to
the truth by arguing with one another
and and and and they don't need to take
on any obligations except the ones that
make sense to them that's it that's the
that's the liberal idea okay so there's
a lot that's Noble there there's a lot
that's obviously attractive there
especially especially by the way to
teenagers who I've had no seriously at
this point of race you know what I'm my
wife and I are raising our eighth and
Ninth teenagers and so we know I know
something about teenagers and teenagers
they get you know they they get to a
certain stage and the hormones are
running wild and they're built to to
start questioning things which is good
that's what allows them to become strong
and independent the problem is that that
afterwards after they do their you know
their their their Rebellion thing and
they're reconsidering thing they're
supposed to land somewhere and start
building something if you have a a
liberal society in which the schools and
the government that everybody the
churches everybody's constantly teaching
the only thing you need is to be free
and to think for yourself
if that's all you're teaching then the
things that are necessary to inherit and
transmit to live a life of inheriting
and fixing things and restoring them and
transmitting them in better shape every
single thing that you need to do that is
not included in the kit that's the
problem is that you tell two generations
of liberals of this by the way this is
mostly the way I grew up also that you
tell two generations of of kids at home
and in school and you keep telling them
just think for yourself and guess what
you the the the the the the the implicit
premise is that they're all going to
come out liberals but the truth is they
don't come out liberals because they do
think for themselves and a lot of them
come out Marxist and some of them even
come come out like racialists and
fascists and and today looking at two
generations of this experiment but we we
eliminated God we we eliminated
scripture we we eliminated tradition you
don't have to be like your parents you
don't have to be like your nation we got
rid of all these obligations so does it
last
no it doesn't last it does it can't
sustain itself because because since
nothing is being inherited and
transmitted basically what you're
telling kids they reach 18 and you send
them to college you say all right you're
you're just going to hang out with 18
year olds for the next five years four
years and and and there's there's going
to be no inheritance you make it up
figure it out for yourselves there are
no Role Models there is no Community
there's no church the professors that
come give a lecture once in a while but
there's no inheritance and so they think
for themselves and guess what they come
out with Marxism
yarm and this is a question that uh I
again have being a recent father that's
made me think about a lot because I can
feel my views on things change as I
watch my son grow because I am someone
who's very liberal when it comes to
drugs for example uh and I believe in
decriminalizing many drugs however when
I think do I want my son to be able to
buy heroin at the pharmacy when he turns
16 or 18 or whatever probably not right
how much do you think that some of these
movements are the product of the
declining birth rate in Western
societies where people delay defer and
sometimes abstain from having children
entirely and that is something that
clearly has an impact on how you view
the world yeah no that's that's exact
that's exactly exactly right that that
if you come and visit you know my
Orthodox Jewish Community where there
are you know there's there's 15
synagogues in the neighborhood and uh
and and people are raising large
families and they get married young okay
and they have many children so a society
like that is a society in which you know
not every single individual but in
general what happens is that that you
grow up with uh with uh many families
around you you you see
early marriage and uh and and bringing
children into the world you're not
scared of it because you know it well
you see how it's done by the way keeping
them keeping a marriage together is one
of the hardest things a human being can
do in life it's a skill you can't just
marry somebody having never seen it done
and expect expect that you know how to
do it just like just like child child
rearing and and and running a
congregation and running a nation
staying married is a skill that needs to
be learned and so young people who grow
up around
mothers and fathers that stayed married
despite the incredible difficulties and
hardship of doing it but they stayed
married for 40 or 50 years those people
learn how to do it and young people grow
up around uh children being raised and
rebellious teenagers who then come back
to the fold and and continue to work to
to to hand on the Traditions these are
all skills that you learn by being part
of that kind of community and if you're
not part of that kind of community you
can think all sorts of crazy things
about about what you can do about what
what is actually possible one of the
things that is not possible is to uh is
to wait until you're 35.
marry somebody have a child for the
first time at the age of 35 when you're
you're you yourself do not have families
around you that are models for how to do
it and think that you're going to be
able to raise your children to to to to
be happy well adjust just in strong
people it it it's factually not true
just come visit come look I'm making a
it's an empirical challenge just go look
at conservative societies conservative
communities and how they work and and
and you'll you'll start to think well
maybe I just was raised to think the
wrong things oh I agree with you and
it's something we think about a lot both
of us
um as we go through our own journey of
kind of unwinding some of the societal
programming and and all the rest of it
the last question in this line of
thinking that I wanted to ask you around
is
how much of an inherent conflict does
there have to be between liberalism and
conservatism because from my perspective
there are things in my life that I'm
definitely conservative minded about
there are definitely things in my life
that are I'm liberally minded about now
that could be you know a sign of my
mental ill health but it could also be a
sign of the fact that actually there are
many portions of these two World Views
that are perfectly combinable together I
think there's probably nothing within a
healthy version of conservatism that for
example says well we mustn't have
freedom of speech it might say well you
have your freedom to express these views
we don't agree with them we don't like
them we don't believe in them but you
are allowed to express them you're not
going to be punished or put in prison
for saying that but we as a society
don't necessarily agree with that right
right
um it may have a liberalism around other
things does there is there an inherent
conflict between the two visions and if
so where is it
look there there are indeed many things
on which
um uh anti-marxist liberals and uh
conservatives can agree and uh and and
should agree today and and and in fact
we need to to be working together and
developing uh the kinds of friendships
and alliances that that will uh will
allow us to to uh to do things like like
maintaining Free Speech Traditions but
there there is a fundamental
disagreement between uh between
um mainstream liberals and mainstream
conservatives about what exactly it is
we're defending even on the issue of
free speech because
um most of my liberal friends are under
the uh the the mistaken impression that
that the freedom to speak is in some way
natural that it is you know that you
just do it you know everybody does it
you know just leave people alone
government should get out of the way and
it'll be fine everybody you'll have the
right to free speech this is absolutely
false but again this is the kind of
thing try try raising a family of nine
children any number of children and you
will immediately see that there is no
natural free speech that the that the
the way that freedom of speech is
inculcated is through an incredibly
painful process of getting people
getting young people sitting around a
dinner table sitting around the living
room to artificially restrain themselves
from stepping look what's the natural
thing the natural thing is for the kid
to say shut up I don't like that you you
you can't say that and then to charge
over and start hitting them that's the
natural thing all kids are natural
that's that's the nature of what happens
when people speak freely naturally the
the the custom of no you're going to
wait your turn you're going to be quiet
until your sister is done talking when
she's now it's your turn now how you
speak it is incredibly difficult to
inculcate and it can only be implicated
through a custom through a tradition of
teaching children how to do that and
then they grow up and then they continue
doing it as adults because they learned
as children so even on Free Speech we
have a disagreement about whether it's
natural or whether it's a tradition
conservatives say it's a learned
tradition that has to be inculcated and
that allows conservatives also to
disagree with liberals on on the
following kind of thing if you think
that if you're a liberal and you think
that freedom is basically the the
Supreme value individual liberty then
you find it difficult to balance
individual liberties with other other
necessary Goods which conservatives uh
believe in so for for for example uh a
conservative will tend to say
having an iPhone with having having
hardcore pornography available on
everybody's iPhone every 12 year old is
gonna in his pocket is going to have
hardcore pornography because that's
freedom of speech a conservative will
say no that is not our tradition of
freedom of speech there is an
anglo-tradition of freedom of speech it
goes back 500 years it's principally
related to political speech we can
extend it to all sorts of other things
but that doesn't mean that we have to uh
you know Go the whole way and say
anything that anybody feels like taking
a photograph of has to be circulated by
any medium whatsoever to our children
and liberals and conservatives will
disagree about that
it's a very good point joram um the one
aspect of this conversation that I think
we're missing is a whole economic aspect
of it in which you look at these kids
who come out and they're woke or you
know Marxist whatever you want to call
it and look we can criticize and we can
say what they believe is wrong and and I
agree with that
but it's very difficult to ask young
people to be conservative when the gap
between rich and poor is growing ever
wider when it's becoming more and more
difficult to own property and a lot of
people will look at themselves will look
at society that they are emerging into
and going well why do you want me to
conserve all of this when you don't
allow me access to it
yeah I I think you're actually going to
uh to like my book on on this score
um the the conservative does not does
not think that the responsibility of
government is only to defend individual
freedoms no matter what their
consequences are so um uh my my teacher
Irvin Crystal uh wrote a book called
reflections of a neoconservative just
you should flag that the word
neoconservative was used in a completely
different way 30 years ago from the way
it's used now and um uh he wrote a book
called two cheers for capitalism and
um and his on his understanding was that
the purpose the first purpose of
government is is to maintain the nation
maintaining the nation means that the
different groups in the nation have to
be loyal to one another they have to
maintain a certain degree of uh
Allegiance and trust with one another
and the in any kind of theoretical
philosophical principle which you know
like like uh like the free market which
is uh which is healthy and good I mean
we're going all the way back to
Fortescue we're talking about again in
the 1400s says he foreske says you know
why why is England the freest freest uh
Nation on Earth it's because because
we're careful because we're careful with
property because the English king is not
allowed to um to enter the home of uh
the poorest um farmer without the
permission of of the farmer all right so
that there is property as as an
important part of this Anglo tradition
but if you get to the point where uh
where the the uh the the uh accumulation
of wealth in a small number of hands
um is uh is beginning to cause the
rupture of the society
well so that's Disraeli right I mean
we're we're discussing what what is one
nation conservatism One Nation
conservatism is the the uh the
introduction of uh minimum social safety
net by the conservative uh the
conservative party and the reason that
they introduced it was was because
um the the uh they they looked at
industrialization they looked at the
vast wealth that industrialization was
creating they looked at the dislocation
of the traditional the traditional
um uh family and social structures which
had
um
uh which which had protected people and
they said look we we're going to have a
revolution and and and justifiably so
because because people know they've been
torn away from from everything that used
to protect them and and now we have to
step in and come up with with a new
Arrangement uh that allows uh the the
wealthiest and the poorest and the
working class to be able to live
together as one nation to be able to
maintain loyalty to one another and that
is not that is not what happens when you
take the free market as an absolute and
you say this is the final ultimate
principle
that makes sense Francis I suppose a
question for us bridge that would be
interesting to ask is you're um you've
got your dream I mean it's 2023 we have
had a conservative left government in
this country for 13 years
right they don't seem to have delivered
any of the things that you claim are the
virtues of conservatism what's going on
what's going on is that
um is is that uh I I mentioned it at the
beginning
that post-world War II uh the major
political parties in the UK and in
America and across Europe adopted
different forms of liberalism and in in
particular
um after 1989 after the fall of the
Berlin Wall
um the the uh
the the the the conservatism of uh the
uh the Reagan Thatcher uh John Paul II
era was a conservatism that still had
elements of uh nationalism and uh and
and religion and traditional moral
morals as as part of the package you can
say not enough you can argue about that
but but it was still part of the package
as soon as Reagan and Thatcher are
shoved aside there is uh the the
movement that that was that went by the
name of conservatism became a radical
liberal movement it became a liberal
internationalist movement George H.W
bush announced the uh the the new world
order in which for the first time in a
hundred Generations he says a hundred
Generations have struggled to try to
reach the the imposition of a a liberal
International order on the entire planet
and we today are going to do it now that
that is not conservative it's not
conservative it's not conservatism
it's more correct to call it
neoliberalism but liberal International
order is is uh is I think the the best
most accurate name for it it's the idea
that liberal ideas should be imposed on
the entire Globe under a single a single
legal system them with with the American
Army and some help from the Brits in
enforcing it and that theory uh has
dominated the Tory party for since since
Thatcher was pushed off the stage and uh
continues to have a strong influence on
the Tories to this day and so when when
I'm talking about conservatism I'm not
telling you that you should vote for the
for for the the conservative party in
the UK no matter what it does I'm
telling you what the tradition of
conservatism of anglo-conservatism was
and I look forward to the the day when
the Tories and if not the Tories then
some some other political party uh will
adopt a a a a conservative platform I
believe that that conservative platform
in addition to Simply being uh uh being
uh correct philosophically I also think
that uh that we got to see in the 2019
election the potential
electorally today of a of an actual
conservative looking platform to uh to
to just to Sweet Britain the fact that
the Tories don't know how to implement
what was in that platform well so they
may end up losing an election or two uh
you know in order to learn
do you think that
your version of conservative is
essentially incompatible with
globalization
incompatible with with multinational
Corp uh cooperation uh conservatives can
can you know certainly believe in uh in
uh alliances of mutual interest in trade
where it's where it's mutually
beneficial in in learning from other
countries and exchanging with other I
mean all of these things are compatible
with with the world of independent
nations what's not compatible is um is
the idea of erasing the borders uh of of
uh um of a single currency for you know
for for tens or hundreds of Nations it's
not compatible with the world government
it's not compatible with a with a world
judicial system that you know imposes
the ideas of of uh of Brussels or
Washington on the whole world but so I
would say yes cooperation and mutual
exchange absolutely but a a a a common
government or governance Over All
Nations
it's it's just poison just say no
you're I think we're we're running out
of time so uh I've really enjoyed our
conversation I recommend everybody gets
the book conservatism a rediscovery and
as always before we ask you our
questions from our local supporters that
only they will get to see uh what is the
one thing that we're not talking about
in your opinion that we really should be
there are many things here's here's one
what is it what does it mean what does
it mean the people that that young
people are afraid to have children they
don't want to have children anymore what
is what does that tell you what does
that teach you what should we do about
it I think it tells you everything if
you think about it
you're it's been an absolute pressure
thank you so much for coming on the show
if people want to find you online if
people want to buy your book where is
the best place to do that well the the
book is on on Amazon or Book Depository
or any any other place that sells books
a conservatism or rediscovery if you
want to learn about and to get involved
with or to just to think about the
national conservatism movement uh take a
look at national
conservatism.org uh or natcon.org you
can get there National conservatism.org
is where uh the young people who think
that it's sexy too
that it's uh
sexy to uh to uh preserve your uh your
nation and your inheritance improve it
and pass it on to Future Generations
please consider coming
thank you so much and thank you guys for
watching and listening we will see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one oral show all of them go
out at 7 pm UK time and for those of you
who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
is a greater danger to conservatism the
left or the pendulum in political
thoughts swinging so violently back the
other way that it goes straight past
conservatism into genuine far-right
ideology
[Music]